intake is new we announced it on the
Anaconda blog a couple of months ago but
it's a brand new project and so I'm
going to tell you what it's all about
and hopefully people will be interested
and start using it that's the reason for
me to be here so I'm employed by
anaconda anaconda supports this work but
it's free and open source so anybody can
contribute anybody can make use of it
for this talk I will first outline what
I'm talking about what we're intake fits
in with the the general idea of how
people going about getting that their
data and using their data and to give a
bit more detail about that I'm going to
talk about some specific sets of
populations different kinds of people
and how they fit into the way that data
gets around an organization and then
I'll talk about intake and what it does
what it does now and what it can do in
the future to smooth those processes of
getting data to where it needs to be
that will be followed by quick examples
just to show how this might actually
work and then I'll wrap up with talking
about what else is out there so first of
all I'd like to ask the room how many
people here think of themselves as
primarily data scientists can I have
hands up I have a significant fraction
any additional people who think of
themselves as analysts or business
intelligence or that kind of thing
a handful okay so I've come to the right
place I imagine lots of you will have
seen code that looks something like this
this is in the context of getting data
into pandas which certainly in the
Python world is the most popular thing
for doing data science you might pass
data from pandas on to
things later but pan disease is a real
in general a real work cost so you
probably have scripts or notebooks which
have something like this at the top you
see the points are yes okay so this for
anybody this use pandas probably is
fairly straightforward I've perhaps over
done the example here a little but you
will have some of these things in some
of your code cells you have some files
CSV very common but you have to fetch
them from some server but to do that you
need some credentials and then you're
going to load these into pandas and
stick them together now you have a data
frame now you can actually do your data
science or simple aggregations or
visualizations whatever you're going to
do with it there are a few things that
are questionable about this code cell so
I'm going to run through what different
people might have to say about this
first of all the data user that is the
person that's actually going to execute
this cell and do something with the data
frame that might be the an analyst or
data scientist that the all these things
are difficult to define exactly what the
different jobs are so I'll just call it
the data user they're wondering I just
had to type all of this out that's a
huge waste of time why did I have to do
that why do I have to figure this out
every single time on top of that all I
know about it is these file names if I
come back to this script in the future I
don't maybe know exactly what that stuff
was does the file name table tell me all
that I need to know about my data
probably not other people might look at
this so the data provider that is the
person who put those files in the place
where you're going to access them is
might say to you hey you you were
pointing to these files but that's not
actually the data set that you should be
using there's a newer one or in fact the
new version isn't in CSV at all it's
actually in something else I have Rho as
an example here oh and it's stored on
Azure it's not on this server you have
to go through an API to get it I'm using
Azure because we're Microsoft it could
be something else
furthermore IT somehow gets wind of this
and they say what what is this why are
you doing this you it's totally against
our rules and in fact then or even your
credentials so this kind of stuff
happens all the time now it's clear that
this just got copied and pasted from
somebody else's notebook right but it's
just being used that's not the best way
to get data to where it needs to be then
along comes the dev oh I've heard that
you're now dealing with have real data
next time but pandas actually doesn't
read from Avro so I'm going to have to
write some stuff but you can do that oh
and it's also another yes we're going to
have to write some more code so there
are now four different people that I've
mentioned here who are interacting over
how to get this data into a data frame
which should be a pretty straightforward
process with intake this is the teaser
so we've gone through this in a lot of
detail you should be able to just do one
line like this so obviously a lot of
things are hidden but from the data
users point of view you just say oh I
have some catalog somewhere it may just
be a local UML file it can be lots of
things we'll talk about that briefly
later and you just reference this file
the write the file itself defines some
stuff some spec and then after that you
just say I want this the state set and
I'm going to read it so this is the
teaser this is why intake can make
things a lot simpler but I'll go into a
little bit more detail so what really do
these different people actually want
when they are trying to talk about data
and use data this data user so the
person who's running the notebook they
just they want to know what data sets
are out there they want to know which of
those do they actually need to use that
job to be able to do that job so that
means they need to know something about
the data some provenance what is in it
some specification of what that thing is
and then they need to load them and do
their job so they want something that
I'll just load the data and then get out
of the way the provider they are making
data for the users by the way these are
not necessarily different people I'm
just saying I know that there are
individuals who might end up doing all
of these jobs but it's nevertheless
useful to think about the specific
things that trying to achieve so the
data provider they will know because
they're the ones that are making these
files or later services they know what's
there but they need to know everything
about those data they might have
opinions over as data comes in what
kinds of formats you should be using how
it should be partitioned those are the
kinds of things that typically might be
done with by somebody with a title data
engineer but there are lots of people
who might do that kind of thing and then
critically if they don't happen to also
be the user they have to tell the user
somehow that this data exists and it's
in this format and you need to load it
in this way IT as we said also oversees
all of these things and has a different
set of concerns they care about who can
get to what data they care about which
data actually got accessed they control
the sets of identities across the system
and they probably are also acting as a
gatekeeper for what data can be entered
into the system as a whole you might not
have a dedicated IT team where you are
but if you're at a corporation that's
large enough you probably do and they
will do these things for you and they
usually don't like data scientists that
go around saying hey I want this random
data that you don't know anything about
and then as the developer again this is
not necessarily a distinct different
person but at some point somebody will
have to write code to load specific
types of data if it's CSV and you want
pandas then you're done but there are
there's a pretty good chance that it's
something else and somebody will
actually have to write lines of code but
you don't want to repeat yourself you
certainly don't want to repeat what's
been done elsewhere you want the user to
you have to be able to use something
that's familiar that's the same every
time and let's say it's the Averell case
if you want to be able to write a read
out real function that returns data
frames you can make a separate separate
package which you then have to
distribute you're probably not going to
approach pandas itself and say hey I
have this new code and I want you to
include it in your code base we made but
that won't get back to you fast enough
for the user that actually wanted that
code okay so what does intake do intake
talks to all of these points to some
extent but intake is supposed to be very
simple very lightweight thing that's
pluggable so that you can add extra
functionality as you go at the moment so
here again is the data user with their
set of concerns as we had before so from
the intake view and this is the same
code tell us before you can open
catalogs so catalog from the users point
of view is some specification of a set
of data data sets a set of data sets and
you have an API on that such as read and
other things that I'll show you in a
brief example later that is going to
tell you what that data is and it will
load the data without you not having to
know anything about the specific set of
libraries and functions that are being
used in the backend it's also going to
handle the specific set of parameters
that you need for that data set that all
gets saved into this catalog
specification which it in the simplest
case is just the ML file but you get
other useful things along the way you
can use the GUI like this which is not
the most stylized thing in the world but
it's definitely usable you have search
options here you can click through you
can examine so you get some basic
details about your data set over here
the currently selected thing you can
access quick plotting so that you can
know some more details basic things
about your data before you go and push
it to your product
Plus that because you want to build your
latest model and then finally the thing
that we've seen multiple times is you
can actually know that in two pandas for
example or other things which I will
mention so pandas is a very useful work
cost but it's not the only data that you
might come across okay it's providers as
a reminder these were their concerns
before so in the in tech view the data
provider is creating these catalogs and
here is a llamo spec so a complete
catalog which in this case has only one
entry called entry one and this tells
you everything that you need to know
about a particular data set so I can go
through this in very quick description
you have some driver this is basically
what is this data in this case it's CSV
you have some description so this is
just free text so that the user can know
something basic about your data you have
additional arbitrary metadata down here
where you can encode anything that you
like about your data you might put tags
in here you might put a creation time
you might put where what set of files
the data was originally based on some
arguments that are going to get passed
to the function which is still the read
CSV function has to happen at some point
along the way and some user parameters
these are explicit things that you want
your user to have a choice over so for
this data set it's going to be some file
that lives in this case in the same
directory has whether catalog' happens
to be and you're going to fill in this
this template thing with either the
value 1 or 2 and the choice of which of
those is left up to the user so the
provider here gets a lot of flexibility
into how they described data they really
put all of the details down here and so
they don't need to direct the user they
just supply the spec which is to be
loaded by intake from the IT person's
point of view then again now we have
another catalog this
has a few extra things in it
now we're talking about credentials
which is the thing that annoyed the IT
person the most before so here we're
loading from s3 in this particular case
and you will want some username and so
on password I'm aware that s3 has a
particular neighbor all of these things
but it could be any system so I've made
this fairly generic so some username is
some password this again is using the
templating system and you have these
user parameters for one of these for the
username you have some default which is
going to look up something in the users
environment or it could be calling shell
scripts or it could be doing something
else to fill in that value unless the
user specifies their own value for it
for the password there is no default so
for the password the user has to supply
something to the system and then that
will get filled in and it will get
passed to the back end when it's
accessing the data by the way accessing
data on s3 or Google or as your or
whatever is one of the things that comes
for free with intake so if you're using
understa load CSV then it can already do
some of these things but if you're
loading some arbitrary or the kinds of
files then from the catalog authors
point of view it's it's very convenient
that you can get to these different file
types you can get to different file
storage systems virtually transparently
so that's one of the bonuses from in
tech the developer so the person who has
to write lots of code again
there is there their concerns and then
here is what in the intake language is
called a driver so intake is a plug-in
system so you can create extra
functionality for integrity easily I
know you can't maybe the people at the
front can actually read the code here
but this is a driver which is going to
create data frames
out of github issues using the github
API maybe that is something that is
useful to some people this was done just
as an example but the point of it is
that the amount of code that you need to
get something done is actually very
small
this of course relies on a third party
package that already knew have to
connect to get up so not all of the work
is being done here but there are lots of
lots of packages out there that are like
that that deal with some specific data
type and a road load it may be into
dictionaries or into something so
wrapping those things up so that it can
produce data type that is actually
useful for your it's a scientist is not
quite trivial but pretty easy I'd like
to say so the developer can write
something like this and this if you
install it on your system will get
picked up by intake and it will be
available at the time that you access
your catalogue I'd like to claim the
intake is nice to work with I'll leave
it to those that try to tell me
otherwise and I encourage you all to
have a look and to try to do these
things the more drivers for all of the
different types of data that are out
there the better and they will serve to
make the intake system more interesting
overall I'd also like to mention at this
point that there are actually lots of
different kinds of data out there that
we usually don't think about as being
data these might be REST API or it could
be some other data service that you are
connected into through your company that
also provides data in various different
forms you can encapsulate all of these
within data within data driver like this
this this plug-in thing here and you can
therefore expose them using catalogs so
that your data users can use them
without having to worry about all the
details along the way
okay so I talked for quite a few minutes
there I'm going to show you quick work
throughs of some of this before I do
that and I have a swig of water there
any points to clarify this moment there
are multiple ways the question for
everyone was how do you publish data the
simplest is to distribute the CML file
which is problematic for some of the
same reasons that the original cell was
problematic a better way to do the same
thing if you want to just stick with the
simple UML file spec is to put that file
in a shared place obviously but that
shared place can again be on your
favorite cloud storage medium the point
of that being that you can then update
the file in place and the people that
reference that file to load data don't
need to know that the spec has changed
maybe it used to be CSV and now it's
Avro they just say not load and they
will get the data anyway there is also a
server in txt server which I'm not going
to talk about in in this presentation
except to mention that it exists
so the intake server is something that
provides such specs and there is an
implementation that you can use now but
it's actually an opportunity the intake
server is a very simple protocol and you
can write your own to do whatever you
like that's worth knowing about correct
there is no writing capability at the
moment it's something that has been
mentioned lots of times and maybe
eventually we could think about doing
that too the reason that it would be
possible is because the number of we
call them containers so something like a
data frame the thing that you actually
get out of it there are relatively few
of those so they could be things like
sequence of objects array data frame
x-ray is the only other one that we have
at the moment so if there's a smaller
number of them then you could consider
making generic writing function for each
of those but there's a lot more input
data types so we don't I don't know if
you're familiar with odo and other
projects that try to do this kind of
thing if you're going from many to many
it's a really difficult job well so in
the Yambol file you're mixing
information that's more protected like
password together with other more public
configurations I mean in publishing
those there's a kind of nice neat way to
can hide the password information and
publish everything else to people so
there isn't an a built-in encryption
thing if that's what you mean but the
example I showed used password
credentials but they weren't actually in
the eff log so so yes but probably not
quite what you you have to fill in all
you have to get it from the environment
or something else I'm thinking we should
get onto the examples now and perhaps
come back to questions at the end is
that okay save your questions there
which we should be able to get through
this fairly quickly I should think
because some of this is repeating what
you've already seen because there isn't
that much code from the I'm calling it
here data science because that was the
most common group input from the user of
the data point of view so you import
intake and then in this case I'm
demonstrating that one way in which you
can distribute your data so I was just
waiting to get to this is actually to
use conduct so Condor is obviously quite
popular as a way of distributing
packages but Condor can install anything
and it can also install catalogs so you
can try this out there is an intake
channel which for the time being the
intake channel contains all of the
intake material and there are some
example data sets that so you can come
to install this and what you get is data
so specifically this shows up in this
if you've imported intake intake cat is
your installed data sets and this US
crime thing is one of the ones that's
there obviously I have a few more and it
is just the catalog entry which it
actually is defined in a amo file it's
just the diamo file my condor installing
has ended up in a special place and then
you can do the the api once you have one
of these is always the same you can do
describe which is some basic information
about that thing that's contained in the
spec itself so we have just a
description here and we know that it's
going to output a data frame you can put
lots of other things in here and you can
also do this cover discover involves
actually accessing at least some of your
data so this is the the next step and it
gives you something that is schema in
the case of a data frame you have all
these d types here it's the basic
information you would expect to see
about a data frame exactly what you get
will depend on the type of data that
you're accessing but it's nevertheless a
detailed description of your data and
another thing that we notice is that we
have so metadata here defining some
plots so in this case because obviously
I wrote this as an example we also have
some specific QuickLook plots that are
defined for us so we can just get one of
these this one was called example the
first one so you can just do dot plot
dot plot by itself would create a
generic plot of some sort which in this
case happens not to look very useful I
can show you if you're interested but
this specific example named quick plot
has been defined in the spec so that you
can investigate your data before this
whether you do or don't want to go on
and actually use it here's some crime
stuff that I don't particularly know
much about but you can see that
apparently burglaries were really high
in 1918 in the US I believe and then you
can get the data so once you have the
data in this case it's a data frame
that's what the spec said it would be
you can do your your normal and as
things to it so I won't I won't do the
example there there's not really much
point and then an interesting thing is
this GUI which again you may choose to
use if you're writing scripts obviously
you don't want to use a GUI but often
your exposure to data begins in the
interactive phase where you want to find
stuff and you want to know what's the
the useful one for the particular job
that you're doing so these are the
building ones which includes the crank
thing which is this is the same
information that was given by described
above but there are some other things in
here for each of these you can click on
it and you can just access it as
Giridhar item so then you can go and
work with it so here is some - images
and it tells us that this set of images
has this shape because they're little
square things and there's lots of them
and you have D type you see that the the
information that you get back about your
data is a bit different for an array
type thing as opposed to a dataframe
type thing but that's fine we we
understand what that means in this case
there's also an additional thing that
this will actually cache some data
locally there's some extra features that
are hidden under the hood here that as
the data use YouTube you actually don't
need to know about in addition you can
add extra catalogs to here or you can
have them automatically added for you
but I just wanted to demonstrate this is
the catalog for the pan Geo project
which is using intake and you can open
it the name here by the way is just the
name of the file that I access and they
have several cattle
of scientific science and climate stuff
on there that I'm not going to read
these are all x-ray things if you're
interested and furthermore you can have
catalogs that contain other catalogs and
you can search amongst them so there's
there's a whole range of interesting
things that you can get into here in the
interests of time though I'll go and
look at the other side of this which is
just creating these catalogs is a thing
that somebody needs to do unless you're
using the small number of example
datasets that are out there so intake if
you've installed some of the drivers may
have lots of things that it already
knows how to read and you can use these
open functions like an N let's just
start with CSV to open some CSV file
this one happens to be a remote one and
this is very much like just doing the
same thing with pandas I I'm making a
sauce out of it so that I can do some
auto discovery on the thing and we can
see it has some some of these types or
whatever this is not particularly
interesting thing to do but it's
something that when you're creating your
catalog you will note want to know that
a particular file does load and that it
does contain what you explained expected
to contain so you can do that and there
it has some some some stuff and you can
also be interested in what kind of plus
you can make with your data this is just
some example this is using hollow plots
and H View HV plots this this package
which is part of fibers if anybody's
been following that stuff but it does
it's the kind of parameters here that
you might expect the point of doing all
of that is that once you have it you can
take this source thing and generate the
amyl for you and you can put this into a
catalog obviously this has no
description we haven't given it yet when
you actually make the file when you
actually make the catalog you would want
to fill in the metadata and descriptions
here
anything else that you might new user to
know about and in fact you want to
include this plus stuff in here too this
is exactly the same thing as this above
except that it now has a description and
I filled in a plot so then you can check
it you can open that catalog and again
the plot is a identical to how it was
before it's just an encoding of the work
that has the data provider you've had to
do to figure out what this data is so
then it's saved in a single reference
place and you don't end up copy and
pasting you can just refer to it and you
can then put it somewhere remote again
so this this is this is again the same
data set except that now it's at some
HTTP address so that it can be accessed
by anybody or you can make a condor
package which i'm not going to cover
cover today so that's it for examples
I'm not going to talk about the server
as I mentioned I'm not going to talk
about how you write a new driver or
other plug-in to go into intake you will
have to read the documentation for that
but I'd like to think that it's
approachable and again there's issues
for you to file if you don't think so
now briefly I just want to mention that
there are lots of other things out there
in the data's fear you've seen all of
these logos some of you work with these
things some of you are employed by these
people and it's a crowded space and it's
sorry and they all do some part of this
I think some of them do more than others
they have different focuses to them I
don't need to go through this in
particular but there is one interesting
point is that sequel like tabular things
is by far and away the most common data
type that's out there and it's the most
common data type there
it's a scientists will use but actually
there's a whole of the world of data
things out there that is rarely
referenced and but worth bearing in mind
and I don't just mean arrays either but
arrays themselves are very useful
so I have a slightly questionable grid
of features here this is not really
features most of these things that are
listed on the Left can do more than
where I put the eggs they definitely can
do more than where I put the eggs but
this is my personal feeling for what the
main focuses are the different things
depending on the front page of the
appropriate website so it's not not deep
research here and there are some
interesting things there there are lots
of different entities but they all have
different particular focuses this is not
surprising the point of intake is to try
to be generalists to try to be very
lightweight and plug into other things
rather than trying to reinvent a
monolithic thing by itself so it's not
going to host your data for you it's not
going to be your credential system you
have to figure those things out for
yourself but you can plug them into
intake that's the idea that's that's why
it should be simpler so this is this is
basically the end of the talk so I just
to summarize the main ideas of intake is
that your users get an API that's easy
to use and it's always the same
regardless of how the data is actually
stored you have catalogs catalogs really
useful you should or already have
catalogs but you probably don't or you
only have catalogs for some specific
parts of your data ecosystem
it separates how the people that provide
the data and understand in detail what
that data is from those that use the
data and don't want to know that stuff
don't want to have to write code or
anything like that they want to do their
work which is making inferences making
models you get to access your catalogs
and data on various cloud sources this
is very important these days so this
will integrate with multiple file system
like backends you can extend it intake
very easily there is a server which is
particularly useful perhaps in the
corporate setting where you have to care
about logging who has access to what and
that kind of thing
and it integrates with other things
around the PI data ecosystem so the
plotting that panda tasks I haven't
mentioned I also work on tasks so that's
a thing that's interesting for me that
most of these data when you load them
you there is a single method call to
turn that thing into a task thing so
that you can work on it in parallel on a
cluster if you want to again we can talk
about that after but the main message is
that people should try it and give
feedback this is new it's young
there's lots of scope to move in
whatever direction people feel is
interesting so and there I think we can
have a couple of questions hi this looks
awesome thank you very much
quick question directly right that the
Condor packages don't actually contain
the data they contain the catalogue that
gets you to do data they can contain the
data so if it's something small if it's
some reference material that is some
definitions then yes you definitely can
include it directly in the Condor
package more normally it will be just
the catalog that points to some other
external resource but you also have the
caching ability to enable you to have a
local copy on first access which is
useful for some situations thank you
it was okay do you have some kind of
like deltas because a lot of times what
winds up happening is that you know
either the the file gets updated like
the same file or it's you know you want
to connect to a database instead of just
a CSV file who is is there some concept
of deltas where you can pick up based on
maybe some kind of day or something else
in tech who is pretty much agnostic to
how you lay out your data if you have a
system that already does that to have
main data plus deltas then intake can be
you can write to drive it to use it but
there's nothing built-in to do that you
mentioned some templating and I was just
wondering how you model like various
dimensions if you have a data container
that may event things by date or by
country or region is there is that kind
of built into your model of a data set
you that there are a couple of separate
things so the templating I was talking
about was how you define the parameters
for loading but there is exactly what
you're saying
interpreting file names or directory
structure so that you can get that
information out upon loading that is
also something that explicitly exists
for a couple of the drivers so far but
yeah the the code to do it is in intake
itself so if you wanted other drivers to
support that then it would be trivial to
set up
all right thank you everyone